pas de chômage partiel pour les abeilles
les butineuses ont été à pied d'oeuvre
ces dernières semaines de bonne augure
pour la récolte avec le confinement les
abeilles noires ont profité d'un
quotidien s'amplifier mais pas seulement
nous sommes sur une année 2020 qui est
globalement exceptionnelle sur le plan
météorologique nos abeilles ont eu cette
chance magistral de pouvoir butiner
depuis début mars jusqu'à je ne sais pas
encore jusqu'à quel moment mais c'est
une année d'exception en termes de
capacité de stockage domial de stockage
de nectar à plaisir 25 ruche héberge
près d'un million d'insectes ses
abeilles sont protégés par une confrérie
qui fait tout juste sa première année de
création
six personnes la composent on a dans
l'idée de défendre l'environnement et
les abeilles mais surtout l'abeille
noire et il ya très peu de confréries en
france on n'est pas forcément
apiculteurs puisque le but de la
confrérie ou 6 et d'échanger avec
d'autres confréries et de connaître et
de faire connaître les produits du
terroir
donc on peut faire venir des cuisiniers
despatie chez tous les gens qui
travaillent autour du miel de récolte
sont organisées par an aux alentours du
mois de mai et à la fin du mois de
juillet à plaisir les abeilles ont déjà
donné 20 kg de miel
les apiculteurs attendent plus du doubs
pour la deuxième collecte
nous n'achèterons
nous protégerons et des bombes doute
l'archi nous donnera